hey guys welcome back to a foreigner
devis tree recap video and we got a lot
of [ __ ] to talk about today so let's get
right into this so the first thing it's
going to be introduced as that high for
the Viking map is now being introduced
into the game again so all the original
maps are back in the game hi Ford in my
personal opinion is one of my favorite
maps is so glad to edit it it's like i
said before every map that was in the
beta is now in the original game the
next thing that they have is now you can
speak to people in game chat when you
face another player in duel this is only
on pc though so if you're playing pc and
dual hook up your microphone you can
talk to the guy while you do them the
next thing is that in busan skirmish and
elimination will spawn 20 seconds once
the rounder match starts instead of
immediately this is to make it so that
people don't immediately rush for a
damage boost and then fight the other
person and then they're at an unfair
advantage also all skirmish point values
are for revives a kills and assists are
increased and respawning is a lot faster
the deficit that skirmish took too long
and i wanted to make it a lot shorter
also in very big news all orders cannot
be completed in pvp and PVE AI game
modes meaning if you have a let's see of
a contract order for getting five kills
in pv / in fall or something you can do
it in pvp and then end it in P Vai it
doesn't matter what game would you do it
technically you could do all of these in
P Vai and you'll still with the amount
of the same steel in the same XP once
again revenge deaths are being nerfed
and one of the few things that was added
is that revenge only revenge attack and
defense apply to when you're in revenge
mode instead of regular attacking defend
stats so first let's say for example you
have a weapon that has a [ __ ] ton of
damage on the blade but not a lot of
revenge mode attack damage it won't
count your regular damage on the blade
won't count when you're in revenge mode
it will only count on the guard which is
the revenge mode attack meter that's a
bit of a nerf there's a bunch of other
things that were happening but a lot of
point values and such all of these are
going to be in the description
especially the newest patch notes for
this and on top of that being in the
description they also added 12 new
emotes in free roam
for all new characters now i'm not going
to show all of them for the risk of me
being copyrighted so i'm only going to
show a few is a preview but like i said
both of these the emote video and the
whole entire patch notes will be in the
description for all of you to look at so
please do check that out and unless
you're going to be talking about it's
all the characters to this update no boo
she got a bug fix where she could
accidentally bleed a player without her
even doing the attack or hitting them so
that was addressed warlord now loses
stamina when blocking an external attack
so for example if he's locked on to an
orochi and a conqueror comes from the
left side and trust i hit him he will
still block the attack but it will cost
more stamina than if you were to be
locked onto them kenza had a [ __ ] ton of
buffs today the helm splitter and foot
strike and now chain into a chain a
chain directly into the chain finisher
meaning you only have to pull that off
that attack and then start the
unblockable for example it used to be
swift strike RB and then into a right
trigger top heavy well now it's the
swift strike into the top heavy they got
rid of the second attack if you use that
a combo it just makes can say a lot more
challenging and a little bit more than
mind games to go off of his side light
attack startup is faster by 100
milliseconds from 702 608 finisher
recovery and sidelight finisher recovery
in in an interrupted block is reduced
800 milliseconds so if he is blocked
from doing one of those attacks he it
will not be it won't be long enough for
them to get a freeguard break they can
guard break him but he can be able to
Tekkit and counter it back conquer got a
little shield heavy vortex a little nerf
that I call it it's the shield bash
heavy shield bash heavy it can't be
chained into a full blocks pants
immediately anymore and his heavy attack
opener which is an a heavy attack not in
guard mode has been increased from 25
damage to 23 damage the next thing up is
new Nobu shishu go kien Valkyrie all had
their light attack recoveries decreased
from 800 or from nine hundred to a
hundred milliseconds like again with the
Ken's a thing they can still get guard
broken but it leaves them enough chance
counter of back instead of them getting
a freeguard break and then the last
thing that they have is for the feet the
feet regenerate which is only on a few
characters I don't know any character
that has it though in my opinion I don't
know kenza has it but it used to be
where you could regen health when not in
guard mode people abused the fact that
all you could do is just swing and keep
suing without in guard mode and it would
still work now what now you have to be
completely idle and if you have an idol
emo that kind of gives you a standpoint
of if it's working or not all of these
Bluffs I just mentioned are now
introduced into the game and the box i
mentioned last week in last week's video
or also in the game so if you have not
seen that video please go check that out
you'll be fully up to date and back to
what I said before the video for the new
emote that I showed in the halfway point
of the video is in the description and
everything else is that I mentioned is
also in the description for the patch
notes if you want to see everything down
to the detail I hope you all did enjoy
this video please leave a like if you
did if you are new to this channel
please hit the subscribe button really
does help me out on this channel and
then that guys and I'll see you later
yourself